we are counting down to music's biggest
night on Sunday and all week we're
traveling down the road to the Grammys
[Music]
Julia Michaels is nominated for two
Grammys best new artists and song of the
years you hear that issues it's where a
multi-platinum selling single now this
music video has been viewed more than
100 million times on YouTube Jamie
yuccas introduces us to the songwriter
who became a breakout star but you don't
judge me
vulnerable lyrics and a low voice a song
about issues became a best-seller for
Julia Michaels last year and while you
may not know her name you know her music
at 24 Michael's is already an
established hit maker writing for some
of pop music's biggest names
including Justin Bieber and Gwen Stefani
in all 18 singles penned by Michaels
have charted on the Billboard Hot 100
and now Julia Michaels is ready to make
a name for herself when you heard that
you're being nominated for Grammy what
went through your mind
my manager crept into my room and I was
like I'm sorry I don't want to figure
out but we just got nominated for two
Grammys and jumped on me and started
crying and I was like wait what does
happen until recently creating
confessionals for other artists has been
Michael's comfort zone if you basically
learn about all of these super intense
things that are happening in people's
lives and because they're trusting you
to help them get all their words into a
perfect puzzle piece there's just this
beautiful connection that happens an
argument with a music producer
ex-boyfriend proved to be the spark that
transformed her from songwriter to
singer she says he became jealous when a
song she wrote became a chart topper and
he was so upset that I had done that and
you had to achieve something so high yes
and he just projected all of his
insecurities on me that day to the point
that I was just in tears Michaels put
her pain to paper the words became
issues a plea for acceptance rather than
judgment a song too personal to give
away to another artist when you're
writing for other artists you can write
the song and just leave it there when
it's yours
you basically have to relive those
memories all the time issues became the
first single off Michaels debut
mini-album titled nervous system a name
she selected a reminder of her ongoing
battle with anxiety I was having panic
attacks almost every day I would be in
sessions and I would end up in a fetal
position for two hours I had become so
overwhelmed that I had just fully
debilitated myself I couldn't do
anything
many are surprised to learn one of her
most crippling panic attacks took place
on stage at the Billboard Music Awards
last May I just literally had a total
breakdown onstage and I remember turning
around and looking at my keyboardist and
I was just like I can't breathe I can't
breathe she's like I don't know what I
don't know what to do I don't know what
to do and I got off stage I just fell on
the floor in a hallway and was just
hysterically crying if this is what the
rest of my life is gonna look like I
can't do this I cannot do this
Michael's does not shy away from sharing
her struggles with mental illness
therapy she says changed her life giving
her tools to help cope especially while
performing have you been able to channel
your anxiety can you work off the crowd
now or how does that that's the only way
really I work on my anxiety when I want
stage it's like you're you're on a blind
date with 10,000 people you're just like
you're like hoping that at least one of
them loves you you know
somebody and as her career keeps
climbing her tattoo is a constant
reminder to love herself focus and
breathe for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles
[Music]
well after looking at that piece Julia
Michael should know she has a lot of
people pulling for her now that
boyfriend that was mad about one song he
must now be in the fetal position
somewhere home what happened
Michaels cheering you on your job want
to get the rest of your music tomorrow
we continue our road to the Grammys who
meet the singer/songwriter Khalid who is
nominated for five Grammys less than a
year after graduating from high school
is a great story - yeah this is great
this guy is fantastic and you can watch
The Recording Academy's 60th annual
Grammy Awards Sunday at 6:30 central
4:30 Pacific right here on CBS